and finally new rule from now on when
joe biden veers off into one of his
long-winded stories that seem to be off
topic
everyone must realize he usually does
have a point
but those of you who are over 50 how
often did you ever see
how often do you ever see advertisements
on television with black and white
couples
not a joke i challenge you
find today when you turn on the stations
sit on one station for two hours
and i don't know how many commercials
you'll see lay eight to five
two to three out of five have mixed race
couples in it
i'm gonna tell you i know it sounds kind
of out of left field but actually
uncle joe is pointing liberals towards
something they need to be more aware of
they have a bad case of progressive
phobia
that's the phrase coined by stephen
pinker to describe a brain disorder that
strikes liberals and makes them
incapable
of recognizing progress
it's like situational blindness only
what you can't see is that your dorm in
2021 is better than the south before the
civil war
[Applause]
if you think america is more racist now
than ever more sexist than before women
could vote and more homophobic than when
[ __ ] were a felony
you have progressophobia and should
adjust your mask because it's covering
your eyes
you know before before
2012 every time gay marriage was put
before a state's voters
it lost 35 times in a row now it's the
law of the land in every state
even half of republicans are for it the
other half are for closeted gay sex
the chant from gay protesters used to be
we're here we're queer get used to it
well we did this is pride month and it's
not even a big deal anymore
30 days of parades and festivals
celebrating a cause that was once so
divisive
ellen had to pretend to be straight
state houses fly pride flags now
disney celebrates it by federal law
every single tv show must include a
story line
about lesbians having a baby
if someone announces they're gay on tv
it's met with thunderous applause
my accountant says yaz queen
you literally can't find a major
american corporation that doesn't do
something for pride month
nascar does it
raytheon maker of high-tech lethal
weaponry that kills people from the sky
does it
and i hear next year they're going to
paint you go girl on the side of their
missiles
[Applause]
it's not just lgbt issues not that long
ago
i knew people who went to prison for
growing pot
and today you can legally smoke it for
fun in 43
of the country and i will
[Applause]
even something like bullying it still
happens
but being outwardly cruel to people who
are different
is no longer acceptable that's progress
and acknowledging progress isn't saying
we're done
or we don't need more and being gloomier
doesn't make you a better person
in 1958 only four percent of americans
approved of interracial marriage
now gallup didn't even bother asking the
last time they did in 2013
87 percent approved an overwhelming
majority of americans now say they want
to live in a multi-racial neighborhood
that is a
sea change from when i was a kid in a
country that's 14
black 18 of the incoming class of
harvard is black
and since 2017 white students are not
even a majority in our public colleges
employees of color make up 47 percent of
microsoft
50 percent of target 55 percent of the
gap
as companies become desperate to look
like their tv commercials
[Applause]
the uh the friends reunion
we just had looked weird because if you
even suggested a show today about six
people all of whom were straight and
white
the network would laugh you out of the
room and then cancel you on twitter
and yet there is a recurrent theme on
the far left that things have never been
worse
kevin hart expressed a view many hold
when he told the new york times
you're witnessing white power and white
privilege at an all-time high
this is one of the big problems with
wokeness that what you say doesn't have
to make sense
or jibe with the facts or ever be
challenged lest the challenge itself be
conflated with racism
but saying white power and privilege is
at an all-time high
is just ridiculous higher than a century
ago
the year of the tulsa race massacre
higher than the years when the kkk road
unchecked
and jim crow went unchallenged higher
than the 1960s when the supremes and
willie mays
still couldn't stay in the same hotel as
the white people they were working with
higher than during slavery and i mean
actual slavery not prince doesn't like
his record contract slavery
[Applause]
racism is still unfortunately still with
us we have the footage
in policing housing job discrimination
segregated schools wealth inequality the
legacy of injustice sadly lives on and
demands remedial action
i understand as best i can how racism
singes a person's soul so much that they
might see it everywhere but seeing
clearly is necessary for actually fixing
problems and
clearly racism is simply no longer
everywhere
it's not in my home and it probably
isn't in yours
if i read my audience right and i think
i do
for most of the country the most unhip
thing you could ever be
today is a racist even derek chauvin
was not backed up by his fellow officers
and that never used to happen
the low point of race relations wasn't
kim kardashian wearing cornrows
even though it happened on snapchat and
george wallace standing in a doorway
didn't
because here's the thing kids there
actually was a world before you got here
[Applause]
we date human events a d and b c but we
need a third marker for millennials and
gen
z b y before you
[Applause]
it's telling that in a recent harvard
youth poll of americans between 18 and
29
72 percent of blacks said they were
hopeful about the future of america
as compared to only 46 percent of whites
i'm not surprised
there are a hell of a lot of americans
trying really hard these days to embrace
a new spirit of inclusion and
self-reflection
and this progressive allergy to
acknowledging societal advances
is self-defeating because progress and
hope that we can achieve it
is the product we're selling and having
a warped view of reality leads to
policies that are warped
black only dorms and graduation
ceremonies
a growing belief in whiteness as a
malady and white
people as irredeemable giving up on a
colorblind society
only if you believe we've made no
progress does any of that make sense
i can name some things that actually are
worse than they've ever been before like
the environment
and homelessness in la and the prospects
for maintaining an actual democracy in
america
but where progress has been made it's
not a sin
and it's certainly not inaccurate to say
we've come a long way
baby not mission accomplished just a
long way
you